[Music]
so trying to fix the whole issue of
sexual harassment in our society is a
tangled web I didn't even know that when
I set out on my journey in July of 2016
and so there's not really any easy fix
and as a result you know one of the key
components I believe is the way in which
we choose to raise our children because
that's where it really all starts what I
found out over the last couple of years
is that we spend an inordinate amount of
time trying to empower our young girls
and we do a really great job with that
there are tons of organizations out
there that do good work but when we talk
about sexual harassment is only a girl
or women's issue we're really doing a
disservice to it because quite honestly
it's really a man's issue you know the
preponderance of predators are men and
in the in the way in which we call it a
woman's issue first of all there's
almost a negative connotation that comes
with that unfortunately and the other
variant with that is that men just tune
out not because they don't care about it
they just are like oh I don't have to
worry about that and so with our sons we
keep thinking that the way in which
we're gonna fix this problem is to
empower our young girls more but we're
already doing a great job at that so
really where we need to be focused is
what are we telling our sons how are we
teaching them to respect young girls who
are their colleagues in school growing
up young women who are with them on
college campuses and then young women
who are with them eventually in the
workforce because if we don't get to our
boys young to instill that respect it's
almost too late to try and change when
men are in their 30s and 40s and 50s and
onward recently I just read an article
about how men are are fearful about this
hold me to era and they're not going to
hire women anymore they're not going to
take them out to business dinners or you
know spend time with them
alone and to me that's really a cop-out
you know we should be teaching our young
boys that this is how you behave when
you're in the company of a woman and
that's when you're you know at a
restaurant and that's when you're in the
workplace so men know how to treat women
but teaching our young boys is an
essential part of this equation I don't
know if during middle school boys have
the capability yet to really assess
completely that the stats show that one
in five girls will be raped on a college
campus and that they may be actually one
of those boys that may end up doing that
but I do think that it goes back to the
whole parenting issue and having the
courage to have these conversations with
your children and quite honestly I
believe that there should be curriculum
in school where you know this is
something that from fourth grade on or
fifth grade on that that this is part of
sex education listen the kids are
learning about everything else in school
I was stunned to find out what my kids
were being taught about sex in school
but they need to be because this is
what's going on in our world right now
so I guess the conclusion I've come to
is that you have to tackle this head-on
have the courage to have these
conversations and and not just say well
somebody else can do the work for me but
as the parent you have to be the one
that's setting the tone from you know
from a boys perspective I can't know or
understand boys who end up being
predators what happens along the way
that makes them choose those paths but I
have to believe that if more parents had
these conversations earlier on and set
examples of the way in which they live
their own lives that the world would be
a better place so I have to believe that
in having more conversations now
especially in this me to era that we are
making the world a better place for our
younger generations that are coming up I
mean quite honestly that's why I did
what I did
it was for my children and for everyone
else's children because when my career
that I killed myself for after 25 years
was going to be taken away and it wasn't
my choice I said to myself in the mirror
one day if I don't do something about
this if I don't stand up and say
something about this who will and in the
end after the years that have passed
it's really about the younger
generations
that's why I've continued on this path
of doing so much work on behalf of the
harassment issue because it truly is
about eradicating it for the next
generations you know I think that we
thought we had already fixed that in my
generation and one of the reasons that
this me to movement has carried on for
as long as it has is because I believe
the American public was so dismayed and
upset at these stories when they started
coming out because they too thought we
had fixed this one of the reasons why
the American public has not known about
this is because as a society we have
chosen to keep the issue of harassment
and abuse secret and that is either
through settlements where the women can
never tell you what ever happened to
them or in arbitration which is where
the majority of employees are forced
into now which is a secret chamber if
they happen to go and complain about
this in their workplace they don't have
the ability to go to an open court
system and so for the last 20-some years
if you had the courage to come forward
and complain about harassment you were
oftentimes put into forced arbitration
which meant nobody ever ever learned
about your story and the worst thing is
you never work again and you're predator
gets to stay working on the job because
nobody knows about it so this is why
I've been so active on Capitol Hill
trying to get new legislation passed to
make this change but that's the reason
why the American public has not know
about these stories
[Music]